ce film a été inspiré par une histoire vraie
sur les gens de Heights qui ont trouvé une
boîte à louches, puis toutes sortes de
choses étranges ont commencé à se produire même si cela
semble un peu mystique ou comme un
conte de fées, c'est euh c'est une vraie chose
dans le dans le  torrent qu'il parle
de différents types de démons qui peuvent
s'attacher à une personne il vit
entre les vivants et les morts et vous
avez cette entité mystérieuse qui entre
et fait partie de la vie et qui, je pense,
parle à beaucoup de gens qui
recherchent  et je pense que c'est ce qui est
unique dans cette histoire et dans
tout le concept d'un dybbuk Pacifica est une
âme qui n'a trouvé aucun repos et
donc elle prend le contrôle d'un autre corps, vous
devez comprendre que le dybbuk essaie
d'échapper à la punition pour ses péchés les
anges vengeurs  volonté punitive l'
esprit ne peut pas le toucher quand il est à
l'intérieur du corps d'un être humain vous savez que vous
avez cette âme qui est dans les limbes essayant
de trouver la permanence essayant de trouver du
réconfort et vous avez y  notre propre âme et
il y a cette lutte
il y a certainement des symptômes physiques d'
être possédé par un dybbuk il y a une
sorte de comportement hystérique mais il y a des
secousses des membres il y a de violentes
convulsions des postures corporelles étranges physiquement
la voix changerait il y a des
pouvoirs surnaturels aussi
le  le cas le plus récent que je connaisse l'a
réservée il y a deux ans 2010 en Israël où
korabik a exorcisé la femme dont le corps a
été pris en charge par un diable et cela a créé
tout un chahut parce que nous pensions que ces
choses ne se produisaient plus mais elles le font
le rabbin invoque Dieu  nom à dire
au Dybbuk je suis le représentant de
Dieu Dybbuk laissez vous savez que c'est
définitivement une métaphore pour toutes nos
vies vous savez que nous avons tous notre petite
boîte avec nos démons dedans et
parfois comme quand vous ouvrez ça
ici c'est inondé  sortir et vous ne pouvez pas le récupérer,
vous savez que
toute la vie consiste à être entouré
d'une culture qui peut supprimer ce
mal que le primal b  pluie qui peut
nous transformer en monstres